adam how are you
pretty good thanks for having me on of
course thank you so much for doing this
uh for those that don't know you or know
your background maybe give us kind of a
quick one minute just on your journey um
in applied cryptography and how you got
involved in bitcoin
um
so i guess i was in some ways like super
early and then kind of came and went a
couple of times so
i uh
the
the
mid to late 90s i was involved in the
cyberpunks list and cryptography for
things like tour like anonymous
remembers privacy for browsing and
electronic cash so i'd implemented some
of the crypto libraries for digi cache
kind of centralized but very anonymous
electronic cache system
and then i came to invent hashcash as a
kind of postage stamp to
make it more difficult for people to
spam
sending emails and discussion forum
posts through
three mailers and uh usually you do that
with
identity just blacklist ip addresses and
email addresses but you can't do that
when the center is anonymous so that was
kind of what caused me to think about
what's the real problem here it's free
let's impose a cost
credit cards are difficult
but we can do proof of work
and that started a kind of multi-year
discussion well probably
decade plus discussion about how to make
a respendable electronic cash
and kind of involved you know how finney
nixon weighed eye and things like b
money and big gold which is some of the
bitcoin uh precursors so that was a kind
of early involvement and then i think i
was the first person to get
an email from statistician at kumuto
sometime in late 2008
asking about hashcash citation so i
exchanged a few emails with him
and so when you first get that email
like why does he email you he she they
and what was kind of your reaction or
what did you think
uh so
the question originally was you know i'm
i'm developing electronic cache system
i'm citing and using your
paper on hash cache
how how should i cite it because it
wasn't academic publication it was a
kind of research report not my personal
website right so how to fight that is a
little
yeah you know it's not a reference to a
journal and a date kind of thing
and
so
uh let me exchange some more emails
later about other related uh electronic
cash systems so what i thought about it
well
you know if you've got some open source
software or applied crypto publications
online from time to time you get
you know developers and people doing
other applied research
just email you out the blue and ask your
questions or send you links to what
they're working on cvo ideas ask for
feedback that kind of thing so it didn't
occur to me the station acrobat was a
student actually at the time so uh
and obviously you know i was as somebody
who'd been
interested in both of electronic cache
for a long time i thought it was
pretty interesting but
you know at that stage it's open
question
i guess to everybody about whether this
would actually bootstrap right so i
think that's what makes there was no
exchanges in the early days and just
kind of you know people mining starting
to
trade things
for bitcoin like pizzas
[Music]
today today an enormous amount of
bitcoin and things like that so it took
some years till that you know until i
think you know there were different
targets like a dollar or a hundred
dollars people would think well
actually maybe it is going to take off
you know it's unclear as a hobbyist kind
of
technologist interest type of thing
whether that would be strap a stable
value and reach kind of take off energy
is it fair to think that in the
beginning you thought the technical
architecture was super fascinating and
uh a breakthrough or kind of a
continuation of prior work
but you had questions about the social
consensus and the social acceptability
and like the mainstream adoption like if
we separated out technical from more of
like the adoption question is that a
fair characterization as to how you
first looked at it
well there was a previous attempt to
boost wrap a system so did you cache but
just by you know communicative users
trying to trade things organically right
so
uh digit cache which was a
startup by david trump opera
headquartered in the netherlands
and they they ran a demo server which is
like mid 90s before hashkesh and
uh
they promised that they would only issue
a million tokens now unfortunately
no blockchain audit features they had to
trust them but they simply just keep it
running and they'd email you some coins
if you just email them and ask for some
and so
you know people on the cypherplanks list
thought it would be a fun prank to
start selling stuff for you know
t-shirts and different things so i did a
bit of that and
because it was
it had bugs in the name people just
treated it as if it was worth a dollar
but unfortunately uh digicatch went
bankrupt in the middle of that
experiment and all the coins kind of
disappeared the double data space double
spend database got lost so i think that
that living through that experience
motivate the
you know the thinking about how could
you make a decentralized electronic cash
system um
there are some more things on the
technical side you know like
bitcoin
took some getting used to for people
involved in
this kind of very
cryptography heavy electronic cash
systems that had perfect privacy
which is
you know to attack or steal a coin in
those systems it's virtually impossible
but you have to trust the central party
where in bitcoin there is no central
party
but the security model
now you've got your private keys so you
can't that's that's similarly expensive
but in terms of
the finality of the chain that's the
kind of arms race between the good guys
and the bad guys and that you know
change in threat model took a while for
you know some of the applied crypto and
academic guys to to come around to
because it was so novel
yeah talk to me about the founding of
block stream i believe in 2014 you and a
few other folks came together to start
the business what was the original idea
um and how did you guys get it off the
ground
yeah so um
what i had tried to do so i got more
actively involved i was
involved in another startup i could
found it before this and i was busy with
that kind of stuff and so in 2013
some price points were reached and i
started looking more deeply into
technology
and proposed what became confidential
transactions just you know talking
finding where the uh people working on
next-gen things hang out which was irc
at the time and so i proposed
confidential transactions as a way to
get back some confidentiality and
privacy from the kind of very open book
bitcoin model and so that was like okay
let's do this let's integrate it into
bitcoin and i came to realize actually
that's kind of difficult to do because
it's it's a big piece of technology
the kind of likes to work incrementally
and it's not very modular so you can't
kind of have like a opt-in feature so i
changed my attention to like figuring
out how to make bitcoin modular so
that's where the
sidechain concept came from and
so it resolved after a bit that you know
that really needed a company around it
to make it reality because you don't
just need to like build a library you
need to build
wallets block explorers
you know user interface
integration so it's a lot of work
ultimately so then we kind of
i recruited some of the
key technical contributors that i got to
know
by exploring the uh leading edge of what
you could do with bitcoin how to extend
it so recruit them so you know greg
maxwell reputable and a number of other
active uh bitcoin protocol developers um
and other guys you know from previous
startup contacts to starbuckstream and
put together a seed round the lead was
reid hoffman
andrew of linkedin
got it and so walk us through
kind of the services that you all offer
or the products that you spend your time
building at blockstream today because
you're not just doing one thing you've
got kind of a whole
you know business full or a product
suite so what exactly uh do you describe
as the block stream business today
so
at a very high level we describe
ourselves as the cisco of sort of
bitcoin related
uh
internet finance
and
so
we're building a platform so you know
there's
it's very full stack so we've got
everything from the physical layer once
we make our own hardware wallet we
integrate everybody else's hardware
wallets
that we can uh
we acquired a software wallet that
integrates with hardware wallets
we built block explorer we built the
liquid network
and that's operated by around 60
different exchanges and market makers so
it's kind of we also make the hsms that
operate out so
they uh the liquid network is a bit
different to the lightning network so it
has block signers and it's organized
more like bitcoin so kind of like a
chain but with no native coin apart from
bitcoin
and you can move bitcoins in and out of
it between the main chain and liquid
kind of like you can with lightning
right you can kind of give superpowers
extra features to
your bitcoin on the lightning network
and on liquid what it gives you is
confidential transactions
atomic trades
some smart contracting extensions
faster confirmation times for traders
um and you know uh sort of acts as a
complement of bitcoin so it sucks the
trading volume out of the bitcoin chain
which tends to congest it so you know
when you see the bitcoin feed spike from
the main chain
i believe that's mostly actually traders
clogging it up
when you think about um kind of the
future plans you've gone out and
recently announced that uh you raised
210 million dollars at a 3.2 billion
valuation uh talk a little bit about who
invested that capital and then what
you're going to use it for
yeah so
on that list one of the things we set
out to do even even back beginning was
to take a part in the mining and i was
to you know improve decentralization in
the bitcoin network which kind of uh
improves uh and
you know gets to low points and it's
it's on the improvement track at the
moment so we want to do our part to
decentralize it to make you know
fully pittsburgh layer 2
uh
more secure and
so we've been doing kind of enterprise
mining
so my hosting for other customers like
fidelity galaxy and a number of other
funds that we've recognized the names of
but don't always have their own physical
setup so we have physical mining farms
in montreal and near atlanta in the u.s
and um
so that that's actually been pretty
profitable for us we accumulated a
number of bitcoin on a balance sheet
we've actually been you know had bitcoin
on a balance sheet from 2014 doing doing
the uh
michael sailor uh microstrategy strategy
before
it was cool and um
so realistically that was kind of uh you
know the bitcoin price solution kind of
appreciation kind of gave us around in
itself
but you know it's a good time at the
moment
we've got a lot of
positive trajectory
on liquid adoption
um a lot of different startups building
things on top of liquid liquid
decentralized exchanges
uh
secure bitcoin secured loans smart
contracts
and the mining space is pretty hot right
now too so
you know one of the
so there's a lot of uses for capital
basically and mining itself is pretty
profitable
one
kind of limitation is there's a shortage
of a6 in a wider market you know even
for automotive uses but that's flowing
through into the bitcoin space
and so you know we do a lot of buying
from
um
existing
minor manufacturers and for ourselves
and for our customers
um but we wanted to do something to to
increase the supply chain and also
diversify it so we can you know
have plans to build a minor
country you know which by q3 next year
we've been working on this for a while
so uh
got a head start um
and just add a bit of extra capacity and
some diversity of the supply chain
got it and so when you think about let's
talk mining for a second uh there's
obviously the china ban um and it seems
like a lot of those miners have
dispersed globally uh what's your
evaluation today is bitcoin the most
decentralized computing network on the
world is it the most secure and then how
do you think about where this is headed
do we get this geopolitical kind of uh
global uh game theory playing out of
people trying to solicit minors to their
countries the nation states actually
participating in mining like what are
your thoughts on mining
yeah i mean yeah i think bitcoin is the
kind of
uh most decentralized chain and it's
very hard to to replicate that and it
has an enormous kind of network effect
and lead time and you know effectively
the kind of die hard
holder fanatical uh
investors are a big part of that right
so
that can't really be replicated to my
mind um and in terms of the
types of people getting involved with
bitcoin
investment class of course you covered
that in your show you know different
public market companies bring bitcoin a
balance sheet uh wall street firms
adding bitcoin products
or offering bitcoin related products to
their wealth management clients
and
so you know we are seeing
um
you know increasing enterprise and
uh
finance firms for their clients interest
in mining and we have a
financial instrument a blockchain mining
node which is kind of
a securitized
fractional ownership
similar to the enterprise
contracts we offer so it's a three year
term product
it rolls up bitcoin inside it
and it's been in it's been operating you
know it's the sales started in march and
it's been operating since july so in the
first
50 days it's been doing about 0.3 return
a day so you know obviously if that
keeps up it will recoup the capital
investment in dollar terms
within a year obviously inputs are
pretty variable it's a three year term
product so hopefully that should do well
um
and in terms of you know
sort of
bitcoin time as compared to internet
times things have generally
moved much faster
than people expect so
you know the prospect of sovereign
bitcoin mining or sovereign bitcoin
ownership
you know take a leap forward with the el
salvador
announcements for example and we're in
discussion with the government down
there to see
if we can put together a bond to
finance
more power infrastructure to do you know
the so-called volcano mining mining
which is a great meme but you know it's
actually something that's already been
happening
in iceland for example
so you think that the el salvador
volcano energy mining is possible and
likely
i think it's it's certainly possible um
it really comes down to cost efficiency
it's a global market and
you know with the asic shortage people
will want to put them where it's most
cost effective to mine
now you know power infrastructure
projects are traditionally very
long-term finance 20 or 30 years you
know to build out large-scale
transformers and power infrastructure
so with the
typically those are funded on very low
interest
long-term
financing terms so if you if you can
assemble something with those terms
maybe with a sovereign credit rating
behind it a lot of things become
possible because the you can kind of
long-term amortize the effective power
cost that way
got it and so when you start to think
about uh inside the united states i
believe you guys have mining facilities
here in the u.s
it feels like the u.s is probably the
biggest uh benefactor of the china
decision to ban mining we see everything
from gas flare capture all the way to
states like kentucky who are driving
kind of advantageous tax regimes uh to
try to solicit minors there is this
something where the united states
ultimately will become
kind of the home or the center for
mining globally or do you think that it
will continue to be
kind of globally distributed in all of
these various countries and it'll just
be dependent on the price of energy
yeah i mean i think it's not entirely
priced so
[Music]
block stream finance is our you know
we're quite a hedge fund and put out
some weekly
financial reports we put out a report
maybe a month or two ago um actually
before the china ban
just observing that the
hash rate had been growing faster
outside of china
than inside for the last 18 months or so
before the ban of course that was you
know suddenly
accelerated by the ban
um and so it's it's becoming more
geographically diverse
um
and we think the reason for that was
the more enterprise
institutional miners coming in
placing more value on
uh geopolitical risk diversification
preferring to do business in the country
where they like contract enforceability
that kind of thing so we think that was
a factor
so i think the us you know and all the
western countries have that going
for them obviously
um but it is it is international you
know i mean there's iceland kazakhstan
all kinds of countries and canada of
course we have some mining and there are
a number of
mining farms operated by various
companies in canada
in the quebec province where we're
operating um
the
the power is uh basically hydro so it's
95 hydro
four percent wind and one percent other
so
there's actually an enormous amount of
hydro energy i mean even just the quebec
province of canada has
more than two times the amount of power
to run the entire bitcoin network that
is unused so there's a core of their
power capacity which is only about 50
used
so you know there's there's lots of
excess power and that's uh you know
that's one of the attractions of bitcoin
mining basically that it can act as a
buyer of last resort to improve
profitability of
power projects
pull down cost of power for
you know via competition then for
consumers and industrial users
got it and then so when you think about
um the actual mining equipment itself
obviously you have uh whether concerns
or interest and making sure that that's
more and more decentralized and kind of
there isn't this centralized uh chip or
or wafer issue
is that something where uh block stream
can provide the solution or do you think
there needs to be 25 other people who go
out and do this and kind of continue to
accelerate the actual manufacturing of
the hardware
um
yeah i mean the decentralization
uh i think the first part of
decentralization is kind of chunky right
so
if it goes from like five supplies to
six okay that's a step forward and it's
in a different
geography different supply chains
um longer term it would be pretty
interesting to see you know more more
variety there's generally more variety
in terms of
uh you know board manufacturer
and
uh
minor branding and sales but you know
even if there's another form of
centralization which is there only so
many factories in the world that can
make
you know
make advanced process nodes cpus and a6
so that's another form of centralization
but those are generally
international companies with foundries
and uh in in different countries and as
you probably know the us has
made some attempts to uh recently to
increase the foundry capacity in the us
those those obviously take multiple
years to build get online
got it and then talk to me in terms of
just the current state of bitcoin right
obviously we've seen everything from
regulatory pressures to some of the
energy flood
but it feels like bitcoin is doing
exactly what it was designed to do um it
just kind of produces block after block
after block is that your evaluation um
how do you think about where we are
right now
yeah i mean bitcoin is kind of a power
run for itself and
people will say glib things like bitcoin
doesn't care but i guess you know to
some extent it doesn't it just keeps
producing blocks and
one of the beauties of the kind of
decentralization or survivability of
bitcoin versus previous
much more centralized electronic cash
systems is that
you know individuals and companies can
leave and join the network at will and
you know even whole countries can uh
restrict use of bitcoin and bitcoin
carries on and you know in certain
countries it
depends on the culture but you've seen
cases where
a country uh like
will ban bitcoin and the usage will
actually go up or move to you know
decentralized platforms for htc trade
and things like that so that's kind of
interesting because there's a
there's one form of bootstrap for
bitcoin
which is that
you know
you could do all word of mouth you know
there's enough bitcoin acceptance and
deployment that you could ask around for
a friend of a friend and financially to
like in person otc so i think bitcoin is
probably at that point
already and the
you know the emerging market adoption is
actually
accelerating faster for payments and
sort of hands-on use
than the west which is you know which is
great and obviously they have more
more limited
uh
payment options compared to what we have
in the west with you know more stable
currencies debit cards bank accounts and
start so they have a reason to adopt
perhaps similar to the way they kind of
leap frogged
and
fix the line to left hand skip straight
to mobile phones right so they have a
problem to solve and so the
street is figuring out how to solve it
in bitcoin
yeah i mean in the month of july 1.2
million new entities on the bitcoin
blockchain fastest growth uh ever
recorded in a month so pretty incredible
what do you think the biggest hurdle for
bitcoin is over the next five years
um
i mean it'll be interesting to see how
it develops of course it's
it's it's impressive how the game theory
you know so
it's evolved over time as bigger players
have come in
there have been some
kind of policy skirmishes but basically
the market has prevailed
and
so i think that's one of the very
interesting eliminating aspects of the
you know so-called block size war right
which is to my mind what that you know
without regard to what people
thought or preferred but ultimately the
market prevailed and that that says the
bitcoin is you know it proved its its
jobs in being in a political money that
ultimately
you know interest groups don't stand
much chance because the market will tend
to sort of around it prevail
so that's great but it makes it
interesting if you have uh sovereign
bitcoin positions mining
so i think a certain amount of
decentralization
and
individuals
and entities hold an end product and
private keys helps if there's too much
kind of etf-like use that could pose a
policy risk because the
etf managers may feel they have a
fiduciary responsibility to do something
that the users
wouldn't want to do i think ultimately
the market prevails anyway but
that could be
uh choppy shall we say
there's a lot of conversation right now
online about
bitcoin maximalism do you consider
yourself a bitcoin maximalist or are
there other things that you're
interested in or open to how do you
think about uh maximalism and and then
everything else
yeah i mean to me it's really um
a kind of neutral
bitcoin monetary maximalists so
you know the
i'm pretty interested in any kinds of
innovation uh you know the bitcoin
sector and
uh
blue sky academic research and a number
of chains have
brought to market some pretty
interesting innovations over the last
five years
and
so there's you know obviously innovation
is great and change can copy and learn
from each other and where it gets
kind of
uh debatable is is the kind of switching
cost of chains so john feffer has a
pretty interesting
uh paper on this where
he makes the argument that basically it
doesn't make a lot of sense to
pre-buy and hold utility tokens where
the utility token is like a coin
that you use to pay for
smart contract execution or storage or
something in a chain
because technology gets cheaper and you
know if a chain gets expensive people
will switch chain and then you'll be
left holding the wrong uh utility tokens
so let's say it's a bit like
you know early enthusiasm about the
internet and somebody proposed
pre-buying you know megabytes of
bandwidth or something in the 90s and of
course you know
the cost of bandwidth dropped
multiple orders of magnitude so i think
the just-in-time argument means that
there's definitely utility value in the
chain but there may not be
kind of defensible sticky
value after you take into account
switching costs and as i say i'm
expecting that to play out
in the market you know mid to long term
what do you think the price of bitcoin
hits by the end of the year you think
about price at all um is there any sort
of uh framework you use to evaluate uh
these kind of cyclical bull and bear
markets
uh yeah i mean i'm a bit of a
trader on the side and was doing some
arbitrage and different types of trading
before starting block streams so
i was a day trader back in the
uh late 90s as well you know stocks and
stuff so
kind of interested in trading dabbling
and trying out the different bitcoin
products you know perpetual futures and
options and things
so
um
but i think even before the stock to
flow valuation model
which is it's an interesting observation
we'll see if it holds
i think the the comparison i liked was
the
sort of
um competitor to physical gold because
in many ways bitcoin is a better
physical gold and so you know you can
infer a kind of valuation from how many
coins there are
current price of gold and you know let's
say that that value gets divided up and
you come out into the hundreds of
thousands uh like maybe half a million
even
on that basis alone so end of year um
i mean the the options prices for
you know 100k are showing that that is
the markets that came that's quite
possible um so
i'm uh i'm curious to see if that comes
would you bet on it are you are you
buying options
uh well i mean actually i
looked at the ledger x
options
concluded that they were underpriced so
i should buy some
basically
i mean basically because you can compare
them to the
kind of not risk-free but a somewhat
risk uh incurring
uh bitcoin yield so if you if you
collect interest on bitcoin
and you can see that the option gives
you less return than collecting interest
on bitcoin that says you should buy you
should buy the option because it's it's
cheap compared to that um
so
yeah i might take a pun on that as well
so because people's
normal intuition is well i'll sell some
options
because i get money now and
you know if if that price is here well
it's like i put a limit order in and
they got triggered and i was
philosophically happy to sell that price
but
now if you look at the price underneath
and you think those things are
under price then logically you should
buy some
when you think about these cycles that
have happened in the past we've
obviously had incredible hundreds if not
thousands of percent of appreciation and
then very deep drawdowns you know 80
plus percent happened multiple times
given that you've got this background in
trading etc the holder base has changed
a little bit there's many more
corporations large organizations
financial institutions uh just kind of
whales in general that are now in the
market than let's say five years ago
does that have an impact do you think in
terms of uh the the continuation of a
bull market is there another eighty
percent drawdown that you could see kind
of in a market correction and then a
multi-year bear market like how do you
just think about the difference of
market participants today and then what
we've seen historically as uh kind of
the crashes from those big bull markets
yeah i think it's a bit of a recurring
cycle i mean some people have been for
super cycles so we'll see if that plays
out but you know obviously the
the kind of money printing quantitative
easing backdrop is is a reason for it to
be turbocharged
at this finish period right but
um
it seems like new participants have to
learn to hold because the kind of
bitcoin price swings and volatility
takes getting used to uh basically
um there's one thing we like about the
uh bitcoin
you know the bitcoin mining products we
have with luxury money now is that it's
a three-year term product and it reduces
the volatility of returns and it has
some downside protection saying
that's because
um
if if the price falls the hash rate will
tend to fall and then you'll mine
more coins than you expected so we did
this in a previous period
where we uh bought the battery of miners
at boston corporate level
uh when the bitcoin price was 15 000
we mined them through the period in the
end of the period price was seven
thousand five hundred so if you bought
bitcoin at that point in time you would
have lost 50 percent and with mining we
ended up with a 25
positive return and then you know when
we went to analyze that we were kind of
like well what's the intuition for that
happening
and the reason was really that
the price actually fell down to
all the way down to 3 500 in the middle
of that period
and during that period we were mining a
lot of coins and we weren't
selling coins to pay the electricity
bills and capital
and so ultimately what gave the 25
return is the we mined two and a half
times as many coins as we anticipated
so you know we we did a bunch of back
testing before doing the battery mining
node and
to get an idea of you know the
percentage of time this kind of thing
happens what the averages are
and what we found is you get kind of
sixty percent upside participation
in a ball case with mining but like
pretty decent
downside protection and lower volatility
returns so you know for people who are
prone to panic sell or not yet
appreciate
the volatility or i'm not long-term
investors you know i mean i think you
know if you were investing in shares you
would not not try to buy and sell them
on a week-by-week basis but you'd aim to
hold them for like three years plus if
you had a investment thesis right so i
think it's the same with bitcoin
and over like uh you know three or four
year period bitcoin has
basically done well in in all periods
right
obviously you guys have liquid uh as a
bitcoin side chain uh many people are
familiar with the lightning network how
do you see the difference between these
two systems and do you see pros and cons
or different applications for each one
just how do you think about those two
different systems uh kind of moving
forward
um yeah so then there's like
complementary
different networks loosely with internet
analogy you're going to see different
protocols emerging from different use
cases and voice over ip protocols like
protocols mail protocols and so we see
liquid for kind of
pro traders smart contracting
um faster settlement confidentiality so
sort of you know people are interested
to try out confidential transactions you
know people use it for what they use it
for right so there are
people just using it as a cheap wallet
to rate the lower fees environment
with less censorship resistance
trade-off
um
and lightning really more for the kind
of high-skill
micropayments
low-cost
um
and so clarkson's actually involved in
both so obviously
three teams
in three independent teams are different
companies developing the
lightning full node implementations now
probably some more at this point but we
we have one of them and it's the c
lineup project
and actually uh
c-lining a lot of people don't know this
but c-lining and lightning in general
can work on top of bitcoin and on top of
liquid so
we have z-lining support there for a
couple years so you can run
a lightning channel that is wrapped into
liquids and that opens a possibility
um for you know even like a tether or
there are some other stable coins on
liquid like uh
the
canadian dollar by bill becklin
um
to make channels with you know landing
channels or stable coins in them so that
could be interesting for some use cases
as well so i think you know another
trade-off is
lightning can only really give you
features that exist
in the underlying chain
whereas liquid being a sidechain can add
all new capabilities that won't be
possible for any like confidential
transactions
um enhanced smart contracting it can
make
you know changes in behavior about the
capability of the chain and the lining
on top of that as well
the last question i have before i let my
brothers ask a couple of questions is
these confidential transactions uh i've
seen everything from people say you know
they're amazing and uh they're kind of
the gold standard uh no pun intended all
the way to uh people who basically
question how confidential they can be
and don't necessarily trust them how do
you think about confidentiality
what makes it confidential and then how
can people kind of verify that verse
just blindly trust that they're
confidential
um yeah so it's it's a you know it's
it's not like anonymous in the sense
that it doesn't
obscure the transaction history but it
encrypts
the amounts of the transaction and even
the types because you know there could
be different kinds of assets and shares
and things on liquid as well as bitcoin
and so only the center and the recipient
are able to see
what the transaction is how much it's
for
what type it is
and
in terms of trust is using you know
similar technology to
the easy dsa signatures and short
signatures that bitcoin uses
so
you know
many people won't understand a very low
level how those work but they have
confidence in them so basically the
confidential transactions is using
the same building blocks and so it's not
doing even though it's a novel
possibility
the building blocks are very standard
and safe um
one thing that that people do worry
about is
an inflation risk obviously the 21
million is pretty sacrosanct in bitcoin
and there are two variants of
confidential transactions one
where a hypothetical quantum
supercomputer
in many decades in the future
would be able to inflate the number of
coins which mostly people don't want to
contemplate and there's another version
which doesn't have that issue so it's
mathematically proven that you can't
have
any inflation so i think that latter one
would be
the one that would be more plausible for
the bitcoin main chain
got it joe john what questions you guys
got yeah i'll go first adam thanks for
doing this really appreciate it uh my
question would be just around
fundraising you guys recently raised 210
million dollars in a series b you raised
uh i think it was 55 or 60 million
dollars in in 2016 in the early part of
that year so from 2016 to today the
market in general has uh expanded
rapidly it's i think it was around it
was less than 10 billion in total market
cap beforehand and now it's uh over 2
trillion or close to 2 trillion so just
through that fundraising process talking
to investors how has that changed uh
from when you guys did it in 2016 to
today
um well i mean when when we started with
block stream
all the way back in 2014 there was more
regulatory uncertainty
bitcoin was a dirty word to many banks
and then we scrolled forward a couple of
years and every bank worth itself had a
blockchain r d lab
and it's grown forward a few more years
and
you know his financial institutions are
queuing up to offer bitcoin products to
the private wealth clients and to the
market in general so
you know it's interesting the lead
investor
in our
b round here is bailey gifford which is
a very large
uh financial institution as i write a
headquarter in scotland is offering all
kinds of funds and unit trusts and
things
and it's i think around 400 billion
assets under management
funds so yeah that's a pretty big
long-term thinking player the other
investor there are multiple investors in
this first close but the other uh one
that
we've been you know we have to ask the
investors if they want to be named so
the other one that's named is uh
iphone x the owner of bitfinex
parent company
and uh obviously they're pretty
interesting for us for a couple of
reasons one is that one of the bitcoin
exchanges
so the crypto exchanges that does most
reinvestment into the bitcoin
uh into the bitcoin infrastructure into
the technology stack you know so they
were early integrating liquid early
integrated lightning that was innovating
and so
they're
you know one of the
uh anchor participants in the liquid
network in the liquid federation so you
could view their investment it's block
stream as a kind of
you know even an even bigger play in
reinvesting in infrastructure invest in
an infrastructure company so uh
that's a pretty good strategic
investment
for us
john yeah adam thank you for doing this
i really appreciate it uh it's nice to
meet you so my question is for
individuals and corporations getting
involved in bitcoin being more involved
in it uh how should they be looking at
it is it a store value is it a global
reserve currency what is like the end
game for bitcoin then how do you look at
it do you see it becoming that global
reserve currency
uh well i mean that's what safety and
moose is uh writing about in the in the
bitcoin standard and the uh
presentations he gives relating to that
um
i mean for me
yes it's definitely got both aspects of
a kind of permissionless open network
for value on the internet and a store of
value like a gold competitor and i think
the
you know the uh
addressable market for storage value is
considered to be
sort of
uh
two to three hundred trillion which
obviously you know if bitcoin would
catch all of that puts an enormous
value per coin
so i think the thing
i would i would see is the next
milestone it's about bitcoin to
you know match gold in in market cap
physical gold and gold etfs and things
like that
um
and i mean i i personally think that's a
very real prospect in this halving cycle
you know for the next three years and
then we'll see what happens after that
and i think one thing that can indicate
that
you know maybe this can be faster than
we might think is a lot of
kind of backdrop factors saying that
you've got the
sovereign interest in
in bitcoin and el salvador a couple of
other countries you know put forward
bitcoin related
uh
currency acceptance ideas that have not
yet passed
um
and
[Music]
you know you're seeing um
a lot more adoption in general and
the you know the economic backdrop
basically right so
you know
a world reserve currency status
historically has lasted you know maybe a
hundred years or something and sort of
you know switched around due to
geopolitical factors
uh economic
sort of strength in the world of uh of a
geography um british pound in the past
u.s dollar today
so
i don't think anybody's interested
expecting anything imminent but it does
seem that fiat currencies
everywhere are under significant stress
and the uh
monetary inflation is causing people to
re-evaluate their investment basis right
it's all very well holding stocks that
are going up in nominal terms but if
they're
only really holding their own versus
empty money expansion have you really
you know protected your spending power
adam i would be remiss if i didn't ask
you uh the number one question we keep
getting in the chat is uh one are you
satoshi and two if not who do you think
satoshi is do you care
uh no definitely not satoshi i think
people get kind of confirmation bias
because they look around at you know
people with
kind of applied crypto and the local
computer science
uh kind of backgrounds and there are a
number of such people around who were
interested in electronic cash
um i actually think it's
you know positive for bitcoin
as a store of value that it's more of a
mathematical discovered thing than that
there's a founder and promoter as is the
case with you know most other coins
there's a kind of
you know somebody in charge of a ceo of
it or an inventor of it or lead
programmer or something so i think the
fact that
satoshi
for a reason is unknown chose to step
away
is actually a very positive thing for
bitcoin and i guess maybe that was
intentional to avoid you know to
preserve uh
some decentralization we don't know it's
all speculation so no i i i don't know i
mean you we can
sort of
empirically see
what kind of
technical skills
would be needed but no i don't i don't
have uh any particular
people that i would uh guess
so one of the questions i get which uh
frankly i don't have a great answer to
and i feel like you've just been around
longer and probably thought about this
uh what do you think the impact of
satoshi's coins moving would be is that
a like a short-term price thing but
long-term doesn't matter would there be
a long-term impact i'm assuming it would
kind of kick off the global search you
know who satoshi in the media all over
again but but like what do you think the
actual impact would be and is that
something people should worry about
yeah i mean i think there's a couple of
things so one is the
assumed number of coins satoshi is
suspected to have mined
is
is a bit of speculation i mean that it's
like looking at pans in
headers of mine coins or something and
so
it's got a wide error bar on it and you
know some technical commentators think
it may be
a half or a third
you know so like 500 000 to 300 000
coins and not a million
as the original kind of speculative uh
analysis posited
and in terms of the market i think that
you know it would just be absorbed um
people would buy it you know there's a
lot of volume these days you can
market sell large amounts of money i
mean michael sailor does it all the time
right and uh
what what you know what what you would
assume
a uh
a rational player to do as well is to
feed it in right you know to sell points
a few at a time
and i think the other curious thing is i
know i noticed a lot of people like to
say that file situation never sold any
coins and i think that might be
we don't know but you know if you think
about it
as there were more miners joining the
network
the more recently mined going to be more
anonymous so i don't i don't think we
have any reason to
say with confidence that he hasn't sold
nicole
maybe he sold some
more recent claims right um
so
now
and actually even in the first year or
two you can you can look at you know 50
coins
per block 444 per day and multiply it
out and there were there were clearly
thousands of miners even in the first
two years and the
you know
a lot a lot more than
even one million mind during the first
few years
yeah one one thing that uh is
fascinating i don't think it actually
matters but uh i was asked this question
once and then the follow-up was
if satoshi's coins did move would they
receive a premium in the market because
they basically would be considered
historical and i thought that was a
really interesting thing because i think
we all think of fungibility esg ofac
compliant you know all the things that
have become kind of hot topics recently
but when you take away the more
controversial you know debates around
those and just say well what about
satoshi's coins or the first bitcoin
ever mined right you know i i don't
think that it would but what do you
think is there a potential that there's
a premium place on any kind of bitcoin
regardless of the reason
i mean i guess people will collect all
kinds of things you know baseball cards
and uh even nfcs of rocks these days so
it's hard to predict but there's a
couple of curious things i think
some of the early
so there's i think there's
mainly only a couple of transactions
that are reasonably confirmed to these
toshi's like the one that he sends or
half any as a test for example
and if you look at some of those there's
lots of
kind of small
bitcoin transactions being sent to it
like with notes on them and stuff so i
think that's just people kind of
you know saying hello to satoshi or
something sending in some dust
so i guess there might be appetite there
was a period where
uh some buyers would
pay a small premium for freshly mined
coins this isn't a period where
regulations were less clear and so they
they just figured it'd be
simpler if there was no previous owner
effectively
and that's kind of what you get by you
know participating in mining as well
that's sort of more of a limited in a
way
but that premium i as i understand it is
largely eroded so
defective vulnerabilities
uh kicked in these days um
and i mean the
the fundability question implied by the
ofac stuff and that that kind of
controversy so
i think it's you know it's positive to
know that the uh
the miner doing that has dropped that
concept entirely so that's that's
positive
um it's important that bitcoin
you know maintain
strong de facto fungibility
a lot otherwise it you know it it causes
potential issues on
sort of reliability or you know
receiving coins and having to check
with a central authority
uh the discount on them that would be
pretty bad for use utility
um
and so i think there's some you know
potential for more
kind of fungibility of privacy
technology to be integrated in bitcoin
over time there have been a number of
kind of incremental steps and i think
the
fishnow signature
uh soft fork that looks to be coming
in a few months we'll do a little bit
incremental on that as well kind of
make more
coins and transactions look
indistinguishable in type
so that helps a little bit incrementally
but you know there's more scope for
kind of improved
functionality and privacy in the base
layer i think
you've been incredibly kind with your
time so i appreciate you coming on and
spend so much time with us um before we
let you go what would you say is the
best way for folks to interface with
block stream is it certain products that
you want folks to go check out are there
other things that you would push them to
go go look at
uh yeah if you go to blockstream.com
there's a full list of the different
platform related products on there
stretching from you know physical layer
mining hardware wallets
through there's protocol work we do um
and at block stream on twitter and then
we have a number of uh telegram channels
that are specific to products as well
so we're on most of the social media
platforms and we have a youtube channel
as well with a lot of kind of technical
presentations and
uh probably this discussion will be on
there there will be a few days too
got it um i asked everyone the same
three questions to end it most important
book you've ever read
uh so if people would expect this but i
like the book snow crash by neil
stevenson i think it's a blueprint for
the future i am more decentralized
crypto anarchic free market world
uh that's a great one they uh when i
took a job at facebook that's actually
one of the books that they gave us to
read so i don't know if people want to
read into that but that's what they gave
us
second uh second question is sleep
schedule as everyone knows now my
brothers and i all sleep on the eight
sleep mattress and love it what uh
what's your sleep schedule
uh
it varies so because i'm in malta some
of the time uh the siesta time is is
common here where people will
kind of sleep
a little bit in the early afternoon and
like some of the uh local stores close
it's hard it's hard to maintain though
so yeah that don't manage to keep that
up very well
and then last question for you is aliens
are you believer in aliens or not
um i mean maybe
you know there's the uh drake's equation
and there's an awful lot of
viable planets out there
so maybe there's somebody out there
far distance
i mean the interesting question is you
know did they discover bitcoin too and
is there you know would there be
evidence of it you know like proof of
work traces or a dyson sphere powering
bitcoin mining or something like that
i literally don't even know what to
respond back if all of a sudden people
in the comments are saying that somebody
who maybe satoshi is talking about
aliens discovering bitcoin and mining it
in space that's like uh when cameron and
tyler winklevoss went and explained to
uh dave portnoy from barstool sports
that you could mine uh asteroids for
gold his mind was just blown
yeah i mean i think that doesn't work as
well as he thought it would because
if you mind gold off the asteroids you
would destroy the gold price so that
would kind of kill the
financing of of your gold exploration
well i mean that's that's the argument
as if somebody was able to hack bitcoin
and steal bitcoin somehow you know
quantum computing all these like kind of
theoretical things people throw out it
would essentially destroy value of
bitcoin as well and so you would be kind
of a non-economic actor to have to do it
right
right
yeah i mean i think bitcoin may benefit
from that so you know there are
white hat
people who will find a floor and report
it
privately and then there are black house
who would try to take money out of
something and i think everybody benefits
from bitcoin everybody wants bitcoin to
exist black grey and white and so
i think bitcoin
may benefit from
you know everybody having an aligned
incentive for its work so i think
actually
that you know even something quite
catastrophic which which seems remote at
this point you know so many of the early
bugs were ironed out
um you know people want money to work
there are far less uh
sort of robust monetary technologies
with all kinds of risk for electronic
and physical forgery
and people tolerate and it works you
know if there was a big issue i think
you know people to figure out some way
to deal with it or work around it and
carry on because you know society needs
a workable money and bitcoin is the best
form of it
today
i
i tend to agree i think you and i see
eye to eye quite a bit my friend um all
right blockstream.com please everyone go
check it out or you can follow adam on
twitter uh your twitter account is what
adam
3us 3us adam3us
go give them a follow and go check out
block stream but congrats on the on the
fundraise uh and we're excited to see
kind of what you do moving forward so
we'll have to do this again in the
future
great thank you all for the conversation
it's been fun see you later adam
see you what's up guys bang bang thanks
so much for watching the best business
show today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you ten dollars in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]